the story that we
look at the world through
first of all the theory is that we do
look at the world through a story
and
you know people are very very attracted
to stories right children will beg for a
story so there's something very
particular about stories that compel us
and i mean it's odd if you think about
it we'll pay to go watch a story
it doesn't matter if it hurts our
feelings doesn't matter it makes us
anxious or upsets us any of those things
it doesn't matter
we're still so enthralled by it that
we'll go
expose ourselves to it so stories must
be extremely useful to us unless you
just write that off as mere
entertainment which i don't think is
very smart and
a story is about going from
where you are to somewhere better
usually
and then about the catastrophes that
might befall you along the way the
unexpected occurrences and how those
might resolve and
how that might change you the way you
look at the world the way you interact
with other people either for the better
or the worse better if it's a comedy and
worse if it's a tragedy
and so i've been trying to unpack
what a story is
a simple story is just a child might
tell it
i went to kindergarten today
you know
more complicated story is i went to
kindergarten today but on the way a mean
dog barked at me and i got real upset
and i thought maybe i'd go home but i
decided to continue
then you pat the child on the head say
well that was a good decision
right that you stuck with your course
despite the fact that you got way late
by something frightening
and so the first story is a i called it
a normal story in my first book in the
second story a revolutionary story
and so
exodus in the old testament is a
revolutionary story
right because
the israelites leave the jews leave
the tyranny egypt
and
escape into freedom but then everything
falls apart
into chaos
and then at least in principle they
find their way again and move forward
it's a very powerful story
how can we know
because so many of these stories whether
they're from you know
ancient egypt or
like i went to egypt earlier this year
and hearing the stories about
uh osiris and isis and
horus and all of these different stories
but that or religious even from time
that jesus was around when they you know
put you know wrote these stories down
many many decades later how how do we
know
if the story is real because memory is
poor
well i think
that's a very very complicated problem
obviously i mean
some forms of truth are factual
scientific truths are factual other
sorts of truths you act out
can you see if they work
and so
they're true
in the sense that an arrow is true when
it flies or someone's heart is true
right there's lots of
variations of the idea of truth and
so
christian's story posits a ideal at its
center
and that's
the story of christ and and everything
about him
and
the truth of that is to be
discovered in action as far as i can
tell acting it out it's a target for
emulation and imitation
it's not so much a description of
objective reality although it might also
be that but
and so
to believe it is to act it out a kind of
ethic
and part of what christianity is is a
discussion about what constitutes the
ideal
that we should all act out that unites
us around that ideal and it also
structures our expectations because
we're disappointed
in ourselves
and in other people
whenever we don't
manifest that ideal
right
your conscience bothers you you feel
guilty you feel ashamed because you're
not
putting forward your ideal self and that
ideal you know people have been trying
to sort out what that ideal is for a
very long time okay
so certainly the egyptians you talked
about part of their ideal was isis
horus osiris they all represented
different elements of
existence osiris was the god of the
state
essentially he was willfully blind and
was defeated by his evil brother seth
that happens to states all the time that
malevolent forces take them over when
they're willfully blind
and horus horus is the egyptian eye
and everyone knows that symbol still
which is quite amazing given that it's
thousands of years old and
horus is the god who pays attention so
the egyptians worshiped attention as the
force that revitalized the old state
and it's brilliant it's different than
thought
attention right attention is
reception
it's being willing to see what's in
front of your eyes
and so the egyptians figured out took
them a long long time that
there was something divine about the
capacity to pay attention something that
would redeem the blind state
so you know all of us are inheritors of
a cultural tradition
it's functional
in the us that's embodied i suppose in
the constitution
but the constitution is dead except in
so far as
its
embodied in living people who are paying
attention
right so
the egyptian pharaoh was a combination
of osiris and horus it was brilliant
idea
so that meant that he was
the tradition that had founded the state
plus the capacity to pay attention um
and renew the state yeah yeah and they
figured out that that was the central
idea the central element of
appropriate sovereignty
wow
right because you might say well would
it be brute force would it be power
there's lots of accusations about that
today that
cultural institutions are basically
predicated on power that's wrong
it's it's a it's a it's a terrible way
to think
i mean they are
predicated on power when they become
corrupt
but you know everyone you know who's
corrupt uses power
no one that no one that
is behaving according to the ideal
uses force to get their way and it's not
very efficient anyways
makes you unpopular
makes you a target
it's unstable socially
it's unsophisticated doesn't even work
well for children it doesn't work well
for
animals for that matter often
so it might not maybe it's not even that
this whether the story's right or not
it's a
maybe more of a guideline it's more
it's more
archetypal kind of
uh
stories that help guide us and maybe it
doesn't even matter if they're real what
matters is that we're using them to
be better
to have good ideals
reels are tricky business in some sense
you know because
abstract things
can be more real than concrete things
like
numbers for example are very abstract
but they're real enough so that if you
can manipulate them you can change the
world
and you know if we if you read deep
literature
a deep literature is
in some sense a distillation of
character
right i mean no one would want to read
just about your day if you described
every detail
right you sort of pull out what's
interesting and relevant and
and and
essential
and so these stories are in some sense
essential
and so they're true in that they're
abstractions that's how i look at it now
that leaves open
the relationship between them and what
we would normally consider historical
truth
and there's tremendous amount of debate
about that i certainly don't have the
answer to that
but
you know there's an idea for example
common idea that christ is the king of
kings well so you imagine that
you abstract out of people what would
make someone noble
right so you look at noble features
across a bunch of
across a assortment of different people
you think well there i could make a
noble character and then you take all
those noble characters and you take the
most noble element of them and you say
that's a king then you take a group of
kings and you say what's most kingly you
abstract out that
right so that's that's part of the idea
now people like carl jung and c.s lewis
believe that
they believe that christ acted out that
archetype that king of kings and so
there was a union between
the historical reality and the
abstraction
and so
you know we don't know what would happen
if an ideal person came into existence
perhaps nothing i mean we don't know do
we